[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr c'est froufrou mais froufrou à
la manière de à la manière de tout
d'abord du jeune espoir de la chanson
que vous connaissez
jeanmis la femme porte
quelquefois la culotte dans son ménage
le fait est constaté je crois
par les liens du
mariage mais quand elle va pédalant en
culote comme un
zave la chose me semble plus
grave je me dis en la voyant
froufou froufou par son jupon la femme
froufou frou frou de l'Homme Trouble l'â
frou fr frou fr la femme la femme
séduit toujours par son
chou ou alors à la manière de du poète
un peu plus chevronné George
[Musique]
brassin
frou frou frou frou pardon je bon la
femme frou frou frou frou de l'Homme
Trouble l'ARM frou frou
froufou certainement la
FEM
séduit toujours par
son pour la
moustacheite par sentimental chevrenet
Michel
[Musique]
Simon en culot me
direzvous on les bien mieux sa
bicyclette mais moi je vous dis que sans
froufou une femme n'est pas
complète lorsqu'on la doit se retrousser
son Petillon vous en sorcelle son frou
frou c'est comme un bruit d' qui passe
et qui vient vous
caresser frou frou frou
frouarç su prend la ch frou frou frou
frou de l'homme troule l' frou frou frou
frou certainement la FR
sédi surtout
[Musique]
l'argent